bonjour monsieur mais garbade merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on l'a dit un nouvelles mesures de
quarantaine pour certains voyageurs en
provenance des pays que j'ai énoncé tout
à l'heure est ce que cette mesure arrive
au bon moment où est ce que c'est un peu
tard il n'est jamais trop tard au mettre
en place un certain nombre de mesures
pour limiter effectivement l'entrée sur
le territoire de ces variants que l'on
redoute parce qu'ils ont la possibilité
éventuelle à ce jour non encore démontré
de pouvoir infecter des personnes qui
ont soit déjà fait lakovic 19 soit qui
ont été vaccinées alors effectivement le
variant indien dit le celui porteur de
la double mutation est en soi porteur de
risques alors le fait de contraindre les
voyageurs venant d'un de d'effectuer des
tests et de se mettre en quarantaine est
plutôt une bonne chose même si l'on sait
évidemment que ça sera impossible sur la
durée d'empêcher le variant d'être sur
le territoire mais du moins ce qui est
important c'est de ralentir ou de
retarder son entrée à fin évidemment que
la vaccination en parallèle puisse
monter sur dans le pays et ce sera aussi
difficile
j'imagine de contrôler que ces personnes
en provenance des pays qu'on a cité tout
à l'heure de rester chez eux
vous avez raison effectivement toutes
ces mesures sont d'abord basé sur la
responsabilité individuelle
effectivement il faut expliquer les
raisons de telles mesures de restriction
mais bien sûr aussi mettre un certain
nombre de contraintes et donc de
vérification que ces personnes qui
savent qu'ils devront se mettre en
quarantaine applique bien les
recommandations vous qui travaillez dans
un service de
de réanimation vous ne vous dites pas
que cette mesure aura pu être prise plus
tôt alors c'est difficile parce
qu'évidemment sont des mesures quand
même qui limite les libertés de
circulation
je dirais pour le moment concernant le
variant indien les choses je crois ont
été faits plutôt dans le bon timing
à ce jour on n'est pas certain que ce
mariage soit déjà sur le territoire
donc c'est ce sont des mesures qui ont
été prises plus tôt précocément mais
c'est vrai par exemple par rapport aux
variants anglais on a probablement un
peu tardé à mettre un certain nombre de
mesures en place malgré tout évidemment
les échanges avec le royaume-uni temps
tellement importante que de telles
mesures étaient beaucoup plus difficile
qu'avec l'inde où les échanges sont plus
limités outre cette mesure qui concerne
bien sûr quelques voyageurs en
provenance de pays étrangers
le gouvernement mise toujours sur sa
grande campagne de vaccination
à l'heure actuelle quelle est la
situation dans votre service de
réanimation et puis dans ce que vous
connaissez à travers le pays mais
écoutez donc comme comme vous le savez
l'épidémie commence à régresser
néanmoins le rythme de régression de 2
du nombre de nouveaux cas de
contamination est relativement lent
trois fois plus lent que ce que l'on a
connu en mars avril 2020 à la suite du
confinement strict donc deux fait
effectivement les cas de contamination
notamment les formes graves de kobe de
19 qui viennent en réanimation sont
encore importants nous sommes sur un
plateau très haut
aux environs de 6000 cas en france deux
personnes admises en réanimation et on
semble stagner sur ce plateau même si
évidemment on s'attend bien sûr
mathématiquement à un début de reflux
mais celui ci reste risque d'être
extrêmement lent et donc bien sûr de
maintenir une pression très importante
sur les équipes soignantes pendant
encore plusieurs semaines
et comment vous expliquer justement
cette lenteur dont vous parliez à
l'instant par rapport justement au mois
de mars dernier alors plusieurs raisons
d'abord effectivement le taux de
circulation du virus est extrêmement
important ensuite malheureusement on va
dire du fait de la lassitude un certain
nombre de personnes applique moins bien
les recommandations les mesures
barrières on le voit tous les jours le
couvre feu n'est à l'évidence a
strictement respecté
même si évidemment il a pour but malgré
tout de ralentir les choses
par ailleurs les mesures plus strictes
de confinement ont été mises en place
que plus récemment sur dans la majorité
des régions et on sait que la vitesse de
reflux de l'épidémie est plus importante
dans les régions qui ont eu des mesures
de restriction plus précocément et c'est
un point important plus toro met en
place des mesures de restriction dans
l'épidémie et plus elles sont efficaces
mais comme vous le savez il faudra les
maintenir encore longtemps
il est attendu que ce couvre-feu dure au
moins jusqu'au 15 mai voire au delà
merci beaucoup bonhommes et javan
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur les
retraites font j'appelle que vous êtes
le chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière merci beaucoup